messieurs bonsoir il y a deux minutes ce
journal était toute ordonnance et tout
poli tout près et puis nous avons reçues
le reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
cuba reportage assez bouleversant et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons un peu changé lors de ce journal
et commencer par les affaires du monde à
cuba de cinq à huit mille personnes les
chiffres varient selon les sources ont
quitté l'ambassade du pérou avec des
passeports et des sauf-conduits leur
permettant de rentrer chez eux en
attendant le départ définitif vers
l'étranger est d'ores et déjà 400
réfugiés ont rejoint le costa rica tout
d'abord jean pierre bru antilles
tout un quartier en état de siège
derrière ces barricades à quelques
centaines de mètres l'ambassade du bien
pas question de s'en approcher
la police veille bien sûr mais surtout
les comités de défense révolutionnaire
les cd-r sont là à toute heure du jour
ou de la nuit
ce sont eux qui font vraiment la loi
dans ce quartier des ambassades
et s'il est impossible pour un
journaliste de pénétrer au delà des
barrières ou même de file mr ici il
n'est pas bon non plus pour un cubain de
s'y promener les jardins de l'ambassade
font aujourd'hui encore trop peur aux
autorités
ces autorités après quelques jours de
désarroi route pourtant repris les
choses en main tout le monde est
maintenant mobiliser bas comme au grand
jour de la révolution les masses
cubaines sont appelés à descendre dans
la rue manifester leur soutien au régime
et elles crient leur haine des yankees
et promettre l'enfer aux réfugiés de
l'ambassade cette pionnière nous
explique par exemple que les réfugiés
hutus ceux qui ont déjà quitté cuba sont
des traîtres des réactionnaires qui
n'ont pas de patrie et saab seulement
trahir et ses amis l'encouragent ou
fille de qu'ils s'en aillent tous cet
homme considère lui aussi que c'est un
devoir d'être ici je suis venu appuyer
l'action de notre patrie victimes et de
notre gouvernement pour mettre en échec
à nouveau les manoeuvres de
l'impérialisme mais qui sont ces gens
qui se sont réfugiés à l'ambassade du
pérou
on ne peut pas dire ce sont des gens
c'est de la merde
rien de plus et cuba n'en a pas besoin
mr nice
derrière ce langage officiel de
circonstance la perplexité se dit
pourtant sur de nombreux visages malgré
les discours vengeur beaucoup du bus bas
ne sont pas revenus de leurs surprises
un grand nombre de familles et peut être
même ici ont des parents ou des amis qui
ont choisi en douze heures de tout
perdre pour quitter ligne
des tambours des chansons de la musique
bref la fête politique des discours
aussi la fête politique comme on sait la
faire à cuba et pourtant à quelques
dizaines de mètres seulement de cet
endroit il y a les jardins de
l'ambassade du pérou avec ces réfugiés
alors des manifestations de ce type on
en rencontre un peu partout dans la
havane depuis plusieurs jours
il s'agit en fait pour le gouvernement
du récupérer une opinion publique très
choqué par ce qui s'est passé en larmes
mobilisant autour de maudore de slogans
tels que qu'il s'en aille que son ail la
scorie de ce pays
le cercle ouvrier frontman en place
entre de la havane
c'est ici que doivent se présenter des
réfugiés qui ont quitté l'ambassade du
pérou après avoir obtenu un visa
le passage par le centre fontanet en
principe une formalité administrative
mais c'est aussi une épreuve
les candidats à l'exil à rita pied ils
doivent affronter une foule qui les
attend et les injurie desquels les
aperçus
oui
la police très présente et là non pour
arrêter les réfugiés mais bien pour les
protéger de la pluie
et malheur à celui qui se trompe de
chemin et passe au delà des barrières la
foule nous créera en plusieurs occasions
montrez bien chez vous que le peuple de
cuba ne veut pas de ces gens
nous sommes tous derrière notre cher
non
majorité des manifestants est composée
d'enfants des écoles et de cd est
revenue là en groupe puis ça mon
organisme
voilà ce reportage de bernard rapp et de
bernard pissos était le tout premier
reportage que nous ayons su de cuba la
france maintenant commençons tout
d'abord par ce qui s'est passé au
parlement un débat est un texte le débat
ces débats de politique étrangère qui a
commencé ce matin qui se poursuit encore
ce moment si nous accordons cette place
et qu'il a été marqué par un
avertissement assez sévère du
gouvernement français à moscou pretexe
l'afghanistan et la détente en péril
porteur du message jean françois poncet
le ministre les abbesses granger
l'action soviétique n'est pas seulement
contraire aux principes mais aussi aux
équilibres qui fondent les relations
internationales et assure le maintien de
la paix le monde exprime pas seulement
une réaction morale
il définit un objectif politique
cet objectif c'est le retrait des
troupes soviétiques
ce qui était présenté le 27 décembre
comme une action limité et temporaire-
tend à devenir une opération massive et
permanente à l'intervention elle même
s'ajoutent de jour en jour les
conséquences inévitables de sa
prolongation en la force finit toujours
par susciter une force contraire la
méfiance qu'elle engendre est
contagieuse si la crise n'est pas
surmonter rapidement c'est tout
l'édifice des relations est-ouest tel
qu'il a été construit patiemment depuis
15 ans à helsinki à belgrade qui risque
d'être ébranlée tel est en définitive
l'enjeu de la crise d'afghanistan il est
assez grave pour que la france n'est pas
renié rien de ce qui pourrait lui donner
une issue il faut quand même se souvenir
que dès le début le gouvernement
français avait qualifié d' inacceptable
l'intervention soviétique en afghanistan
mais jamais et c'est pour cette raison
qu'on avait parlé à l'époque
d'hésitation de la diplomatie française
jamais cette intervention n'avait été
condamné aussi durement aussi clairement
qu'aujourd'hui par monsieur jean
françois poncet il s'agit sans doute
d'un tournant important dans les
relations entre paris moscou puisque en
demandant le retrait pur et simple des
troupes soviétiques d'afghanistan
le gouvernement français auront avec le
sacro saint principe de non-ingérence
qui régissait jusqu'à maintenant les
rapports entre les deux pays
si monsieur coup de murville au nom du
rpr a voté a regretté que cette
condamnation ne survienne un peu tard le
gouvernement français bien décider
désormais à dire des vérités même
désagréables gouvernement soviétique est
l'occasion s'en présentera dans quelques
jours le 23 avril exactement lors de la
visite de monsieur andré gromyko le
ministre soviétique des affaires
étrangères à paris
cependant quelle que soit la gravité de
la situation internationale le
gouvernement français est décidé à
continuer le dialogue avec moscou un
dialogue que les américains et les
allemands veulent également poursuivre
mais pour les gouvernements occidentaux
reste à savoir maintenant quelle sera la
limite de ce dialogue
au moment justement où ces occidentaux
affirment tous unanimement que ce sont
les soviétiques et eux seuls qui rompent
la détente et qui met dangereusement l'
équilibre du monde en péril
puis ce rappel de jean françois-poncet
la politique étrangère française ne se
détermine pas en fonction de ce que
pensent ou disent les autres pays elle
est indépendante ce qu'a contesté
d'ailleurs le communiste robert monde
argent c'était de la part du ministre
une manière de réponse à l'appel de
jimmy carter aux occidentaux pas traiter
que d'importance sur le fond la part des
gaullistes représenter tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée par maurice couve de
murville en revanche du côté socialiste
une série de reproches avancée par
françois mitterrand est tout d'abord
celui ci à propos du proche orient
le gouvernement parle un double langage
celui des palestiniens golf et puis un
tout autre
dès lors qu'il s'agit
de s'adresser à paris aux israéliens
essaient simplement cette séparation
quel est le sentiment aux faux de
vouloir plaire successivement à tout le
monde ce qui bien entendu c'est la
meilleure façon au bout du compte de ne
plaire à personne ou d'être 6 p à chacun
tout à l'heure dans un mouvement
vertueux qui ne m'étonne pas de vous et
se met à faire de jolis comment
aurait-on pu supposer que l'attitude du
président la république aurait pu être
inspiré par de vils considération
touchante à des intérêts économiques
tout le monde a compris le pétrole mais
tout le monde avait pensé pétrole avant
vous monsieur mes affaires étrangères et
si vous avez été obligé d'insérer ce
passage délicat dans votre exposé écrit
ses percées bien parce que vous savez
que si c'était israël qui est vêtu
pétrole
le discours du président la république
aurait peut-être été différent deuxième
sujet de passion pour les députés la
sphère de breuil pour l'instant
transformé en mines est mise en
accusation de michel poniatowski
le dossier n'a pas été abordée en
science publique mais devant le bureau
de l'assemblée nationale etc décidées
depuis l'heure du déjeuner une
commission de 15 députés de tous gros va
examiner la demande des socialistes
qu'ils souhaitent sur le rappelle la
mise en accusation de l'ancien ministre
de l'intérieur devant la haute cour de
justice pour position est recevable a
dit bureau de l'assemblée mais celle des
communistes ne l'est pas pour des
raisons de forme clady on peut dire que
la machine est élancé à la commission de
travailler maintenant alors dernier
drame comment ça s'est passé ce matin
le président chaban delmas a même moment
vers ses collègues de laisser toute
arrière pensée politique au vestiaire
pour ne se prononcer que ans juriste et
à leurs résultats une des propriétés de
proposition adoptée par 12 voix contre
aussi celle des socialistes le rpr ayant
goûté il avait donné trois de ses voix à
cette proposition
vive réaction immédiate de monsieur
hamel udf
il s'agit là d'un règlement de comptes
politique par une protestation d'émotion
au coeur socialiste adultes ou
incrimination ne veut pas du tout dire
condamnation alors vous l'avez dit les
communistes ont vu leur proposition
refusée pour vise le top des faut dire
que monsieur chaban delmas
sur le plan du droit strict avait penché
dans ce sens mais ça nous a valu dans
les pouvoirs une grosse colère de
monsieur bélanger qui a dénoncé les
petites manoeuvres de petite envergure
de petits personnages et tout ça est
minable activée quant à monsieur chine
aux quelques instants après il nous a
dit qu'il s'inclinait devant la décision
juridique prise par le bureau et que le
groupe désignerait marvie ses quatre
représentants pour siéger à la
commission
il sera en piste à partir de mercredi
est ce qu'on peut dire daniel que pour
reprendre l'expression d'un ami
politique de monsieur connaît aussi que
de la mise en accusation que la mise à
mort politique de monsieur prier d'auxi
a commencé écoutez je vois que c'est
aller bien vite en tous les cas
l'opposition sont des formes il est
évident qu'elle ne serait pas fâché de
voir éliminé de la scène politique n'a
jamais ménagé les coûts et qui de plus
se réclament du président de la
république pour le rpr c'est beaucoup
plus complexe monsieur l'abbé m'a dit
encore il ya quelques instants
nous préférerions de beaucoup un
règlement judiciaire
d'autant plus que la procédure qui est
engagée et risque de nous mener beaucoup
plus loin que nous ne le souhaitons le
jeu reste vis-à-vis des institutions et
sur ce point il rejoignait un très haut
personnage du parlement
il m'a confié cet appel au guide contre
de justice a été prévu pour défendre la
république et pour la faire respecter et
je ne crois pas que le chemin trim pour
éclaircir une affaire qui doivent être
éclaircis soit finalement le meilleur
place maintenant sur europe 1 michel
pedowski a confirmé une fois de plus
qu'il ignorait les menaces de mort qui
faisait sur jean de braye et qu'il n'y
avait pas de raison pour qu'il ne puisse
pas poursuivre les députés qu'il accuse
malgré l'article 26 de la constitution
qui stipule qu'aucun membre du parlement
ne peut être jugé à l'occasion des
opinions ou votes qu'il a émis dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions
toujours au parlement le député
socialiste pierre j'adorais député de
lannion a demandé un débat d'urgence sur
le naufrage du tanio je rappelle que
mercredi prochain une délégation de 13
élus des côtes du nord seront reçus par
le chef de l'état ils ont dit oui
aujourd'hui et puis ce dernier mot sur
la politique pour vous dire que le
secrétariat du parti socialiste s'étonne
de la visite de michel rocard à londres
à l'invitation du gouvernement
conservateur dans l'âme soeur
nous n'avons pas été informés dit on au
siège du ps michel rocard n'a pas de
mandat pour cela revenons maintenant aux
affaires du monde avec ce qui vient de
se passer en tunisie l'irréparable a été
commis à gafsa ce matin 13 des 15
condamnés à mort ont été pendus toutes
les demandes de recours en grâce nous
donc servi à rien la dernière émane et
des communistes français et des
parlementaires européens
le commando tunisien entraînée en libye
pour déstabiliser le régime tunisien a
donc été anéanties serge me serais du 10
au 27 mars dernier s'est déroulé à tunis
le procès d'une soixantaine de personnes
accusées de tentative de renversement du
régime par la force
c'est ainsi qu'ils étaient qualifiés
l'attaquent à laquelle ses hommes
avaient participé contre la cité minière
de gafsa
dans la nuit du 26 au 27 janvier attaque
au cours de laquelle une cinquantaine de
personnes civiles et militaires
tunisiens avaient été tués les commandos
s'étaient infiltrés en tunisie par
l'algérie ils venaient de libye
la justice tunisienne a été extrêmement
rapide moins de deux mois après ces
événements la cour de sûreté de l'état
après un procès qui a suscité bien des
remous a prononcé quinze condamnations à
mort dont deux par contumace
le procureur avait requis la peine
capitale pour les quelques 30 inculpé
pris les armes à la main
à la suite de ce verdict on avait laissé
entendre à tunis que le président
bourguiba pourrait exercer son droit de
grâce
or il ne l'a pas fait les responsables
tunisiens entendent décourager de la
sorte toute nouvelle tentative mais est
ce bien la meilleure manière
le parlement européen dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure réuni à
strasbourg aujourd'hui a également
marqué aujourd'hui sa solidarité avec
les états unis dans la sphère des otages
de téhéran le parlement a adopté une
proposition de résolution suggérant la
suspension des relations diplomatiques
avec l'iran
le parlement réclame à nouveau une
libération rapide des otages à téhéran
précisément l'imam khomeiny a déclaré
sur radio téhéran que l'iran briserait
l'irak et avancerait jusqu'à bagdad dire
henry connaît depuis quelques semaines
des incidents de frontière vous savez
avec l'irak
en décidant de boycotter les jeux de
moscou les états unis vous savez
applique une sanction politique
en réponse à l'invasion de l'afghanistan
par l'armée rouge mais cette décision
n'est pas sans conséquence non plus aux
états unis sans conséquences économiques
en effet bon nombre de contrats
commerciaux sont purement et simplement
annulé d'un portage de jacques seigner
et jean-louis safari
la route de moscou et poupées pour les
ordinateurs mais ce n'est pas le seul
secteur de l'activité commerciale
américaine qui se trouve affecté par la
décision du boycottage première victime
une grande marque de blue jeans la plus
célèbre qui a investi plus de 12
millions de dollars en uniforme qui
devait être porté par les athlètes
américains et par tous les officiels de
moscou soit 23 mille personnes et on
regrette surtout l'occasion manquée de
lancer nouvelle ligne de chip tant
appréciée dans les pays de l'est comme
en témoigne ce touristes bulgares de new
york qui n'avait qu'un slogan la bouche
de jean c'est de la bonne qualité par
des hamburgers non plus à moscou dont la
distribution devait être assurée par une
marque américaine et stupeur pas de coca
cola
malgré un contrat signé de longue date
et un budget publicitaire de 50 millions
et c'est une catastrophe puisque moscou
et était l'occasion peut briser le
monopole mais oui le monopole pepsi cola
qui a pignon sur le kremlin depuis le
jour où richard nixon avait facilité un
de ses bons amis l'accès de la boisson
capitaliste sur les tables socialiste
pas de coca cola donc pour mischa
l'ourson mascotte hélas moins de
visiteurs qui ne pourront photographier
micha avec la célèbre marque japonaise
clic clac et dans les agences de voyage
new york
c'est presque la peine nous avions près
de 11000 personnes inscrites pour moscou
et depuis la date limite d'annulation du
1er mars
il ne reste plus que trois mille cinq
cents personnes qui ont confirmé leur
voyage pour les jeux 100 millions de
dollars de pertes pour les 58 firmes qui
ont préparé des micha tischer micha
porte clés et micha souvenez mais les
compagnies d'assurance la l'oeil
notamment font grise mine à l'idée de
dédommager la chaîne nbc
vient d'annoncer officiellement qu'elle
ne retransmettra pas les jeux dont elle
avait acheté les droits pour 87 millions
de dollars
aujourd'hui le conseil d'administration
du fonds monétaire international a
décidé que le gouvenement de la
république populaire de chine ferait
partie désormais du fmi fonds monétaire
international chine précisément le
voyage de tai po berlinger a fait qu'un
marque un net rapprochement des partis
communistes italiens et chinois
et ce sans porter préjudice à quelconque
à quiconque affirme enrico berlinguer
faisant bien sûr allusion aux
particuliers soviétique
le vice-premier ministre deng xiaoping a
lui déclaré que la guerre était
inévitable mais qu'il fallait faire en
sorte qu'elles éclatent le plus tard
possible
une tradition parce que si un qui pense
que fraîchement naim les obsèques de
jean paul sartre initialement prévu pour
vendredi sont repoussé à samedi selon
ses volontés jean paul ça va être
incinérés je vous le rappelle mais cette
cérémonie qui aura lieu dans l'intimité
ne pourra avoir lieu que dans le courant
de la semaine prochaine au père lachaise
le cortège partira partira donc samedi à
14h l'hôpital broussais et se rendra
directement au cimetière montparnasse
justice verdict cet après midi à nantes
dans le procès de jean claude debons
paix qui avait tué sa femme pour garder
ses enfants
dix ans de réclusion criminelle alors
glace ce drame douloureux il ya
l'affrontement de deux causes
le mouvement des pères divorcés soutien
à celle des pères qui veulent se voir
garder confier la garde de leurs enfants
après le divorce et puis l'association
sos femmes battues elles s'étaient
mobilisés pour défendre la mémoire de la
victime claude sérillon une gerbe de
fleurs à la mémoire de la victime sur
les marches du palais de justice hier
matin au nom des femmes battues
terrorisé par leurs maris une gerbe au
nom de la cause des femmes
un geste de trop sans doute ce n'était
vraiment pas le bon combat pas plus
celui des pères divorcés de la garde des
enfants de la condition paternelle au
nom de laquelle se distribuaient
d'autres tracts dans la salle des pas
perdus
non jean claude bonpaix attiré cinq fois
sur sa femme il ne supportait pas
l'ombre d'un rival
il n'acceptait pas la liberté que sa
femme tentait de reprendre les jurés de
nantes ont vu impitoyable meurtrier dire
entre deux sanglots
nous étions normaux heureux de vivre où
il devait bien y avoir de l'amour de la
passion dans ce couple mais on en
parlera peu on assistera plutôt un
lamentable défilé de témoins trop près
excessive dans leur haine dans leur
amitié
pourtant assurera l'avocate des intérêts
des femmes de la famille de la victime
il ne s'agit pas d'accuser mais de
témoigner
il faut que bonpaix comprennent qu'ils
n'avaient pas à revendiquer les enfants
que sa femme voulait être libre
simplement en accord sur ce dernier
point l'avocat général s'attachera à
prouver la préméditation de l'acte
l'accusé était venu pour tuer les
enfants étaient un moyen de chantage
ce sont des hypothèses on n'est pas
loyal avec l'accusé plaidera avec
beaucoup d'intelligence l'avocat de la
défense était alors la fin du procès il
n'était plus question que d'un mari trop
jaloux trop exclusif d'un meurtrier
condamné donc à dix années de réclusion
dix années pendant lesquelles selon
l'expression de son défenseur deux
enfants devront se promener entre la
photo de leur mère accroché dans leur
chambre et la prison où sera détenue
leur père à l'instant sept dernières
nouvelles en provenance de belgique un
accord pour un grognement tripartite
c'est à dire les six présidents des
partis traditionnels belges se sont mis
d'accord pour la constitution donc d'un
futur cabinet voilà une bouffée d'air
dans ce journal maintenant des milliers
de saumon en auvergne où on ne l'avait
pas vu depuis 40 ans et poissons qui ont
remonté la loire le puy saint nazaire se
trouve actuellement bloqués dans le plan
d'eau de vichy
les pêcheurs n'ont qu'à bien se tenir
c'est toi ils sont revenus les saumons
ils ont quitté leurs zones
d'engraissement pour la plupart en
écosse ils ont remonté la loire et ils
sont maintenant dans les autres et
oxygénées de l'allier à 800 km de la mer
là où ils sont nés il y a cinq ou six
ans là où maintenant ils veulent donner
la vie c'est un retour inespéré mais
c'est peut-être le dernier quart de plus
en plus les saumons sont retardés voire
bloqués par les gravières et les
barrages à vichy l'association de
protection du saumon veut engager une
action en justice contre la ville
son barrage maintenu fermées empêchent
la migration des poissons vers l'amont
de la rivière or s'il pouvait atteindre
leurs frayères le stock des saumons de
la liez aurait reconstitué ses 10 ans et
loire jusqu'à prévoir la municipalité de
vichy fait là celle de rennes ce qui
arrange bien quelques pêcheurs avec 2,66
ont été pris la semaine dernière puis
dont quelques pièces rares je suis au
bon dieu au nom et banjo de merde ça
fait cinquante premiers à cinq ans au
contraire je suis tout à fait que le
fichier très bonne pour la forme celle
des saumons comme la nôtre cyclisme
maintenant les coureurs italiens en
verve en effet après la victoire de
francesco moser dans paris roubaix
aujourd'hui c'est son compatriote
saronni de cp pharaonique qui a emporté
assez facilement le chiva lors de sa
première grande victoire de la saison
il devance une autre et doit nielsen
grand animateur de la course bernard
official in troisième à l'arrivée il a
expliqué cette demie des pets par
l'erreur qu'il a commise dans le choix
de son brad et moi tels que la prochaine
épreuve cycliste aura lieu dimanche avec
liège passionne bâtonnier hier à
l'arrivée donc de sa renault
et puis un autre sport un peu spéciale
avec une finit pas toujours très bien le
record du monde de saut en automobile
c'est un cascadeur français qui vient de
le battre
laurent massardier vous commandent ces
images assez étonnante
c'était hier soir à aix les bains au
cours d'une démonstration de cascadeur
au volant de cette carcasse qui était au
départ une 404 diesel
jean paul chirouze cascadeur
professionnel propulsé par un tremplin à
140 kilomètres heure
il a survolé une des deux voitures pour
atterrir exactement 59 m 48 lointain
battant ainsi son propre record du monde
46 ans dans ce genre d'exploit tout
était prévu mais hier une fois en vue de
remplacer des faits l'automobile
déséquilibrait a percuté l'eau sur le
côté conducteur
jean paul cheyrou s'est fracturé la
clavicule et le poignet hospitalisé il
parle pourtant déjà de recommencer la
météo maintenant aujourd'hui le temps a
été très doux le ciel assez nuageux sur
le sud de la france où il est même plus
par endroits mais le reste du pays a
connu le soleil alors laurent broomhead
quelles sont vos prévisions pour demain
après demain et dimanche est possible
dans l'ensemble on peut dire qu'elles
sont bonnes il fera et fera beau
pourquoi parce qu'il ya l'anticyclone
qui est sur l'atlantique qui se
rapproche tout même je pense qu'à partir
de samedi et surtout dimanche il fera un
peu plus frais dans le nord est du pays
enfin voyons d'abord la carte pour
demain sur l'ensemble du pays beaucoup
de soleil tout de même deux petites
sombre au tableau d'abord sur le l'est
du pays et le nord-est où des petits
passages de nuages de nom éventuellement
quelques petites pluies
mais dès l'après midi il fera à nouveau
du soleil est dit là s'ils reviendront
puis il s'améliore tout de même
lentement sur l'extrême sud du pays des
pyrénées au sud du massif central au sud
des alpes et à la corse où l'ia vous
l'avez dit patrick beaucoup de nuages en
ce moment et des pluies mais c'est plus
auront tendance à faiblir et demain ce
seront surtout sous forme d'orages
depuis les côtes de la méditerranée
jusqu'à l'accord ça s'améliorera par la
suite vers la fin elle mène oui et 2
précisant que pour la fin de semaine
pour samedi comme pour demain il y aura
dans toutes les autres régions effets du
soleil de la brune le matin
principalement de l'aquitaine au centre
ouest du pays bon pied dissipe dans la
journée pour samedi donc et bien
amélioration dans le sud il y aura
encore quelques ondées orageuses de la
méditerranée à la corse dans l'extrême
sud-est
mais ce sera nettement moins grave
partout ailleurs un peu plus de soleil
en particulier dans le nord-est m
fois dans la journée une petite ligne de
pluie arrivera par le nord ouest
disons de la manche orientale et aux
flandres pour gagner le soir les
frontières de l'est
c'est dire qu'il y aura à nouveau des
nuages et peut-être quelques pluies dans
ces régions alors ne perdez des
éclaircies surface du pays continuera à
faire bon quant à dimanche et bien je
pense que malheureusement ces deux zones
de nuages dernière un petit peu vers le
sud on devrait la retrouver
de la normandie carrément jusqu'au sud
est du pays où furent un peu plus de
nuages dans le nord-est
merci laurent le tir c'est la
combinaison gagnante c'est le 8 4 2 qui
vous rapportent dans l'ordre 6033 francs
et dans un ordre différent pour 5 francs
bien sûr 758 francs pas ce soir vous
allez rendez vous vers 23h20 avec
pierre-alain pour les dernières
nouvelles et puis demain toute la
rédaction de rennes ii se déplacera à
marseille joue tous vos journaux
télévisés vous seront présentés en
direct à 12h45 l'invité sera par exemple
garçons de faire noël mamère sera là bas
pour c'est la vie à 18h30 et moi même a
le plaisir de vous retrouver à 20h de
marseille selon elle est maintenant
terminée bonsoir données